before I turn to this evening's
announcements I want to update you on
the latest data three million five
hundred and thirty two thousand six
hundred and thirty-four tests for
coronavirus have now been carried out in
the UK including seventy three thousand
seven hundred and twenty six tests
carried out yesterday two hundred sixty
one thousand one hundred eighty four
people have tested positive and that's
an increase of 1625 cases since
yesterday eight thousand eight hundred
and thirty-four people are in hospital
with coded nineteen in the UK and that's
Dan tow percent from ten thousand and
ninety two this time last week and sadly
of those who tested positive for
coronavirus across all settings 36
thousand nine hundred and fourteen have
now died that's an increase of one
hundred and twenty one fatalities since
yesterday and this new figure includes
deaths in all settings not just in
hospitals and once again my deepest
condolences go out to all those who have
lost their loved ones before their time
and we must and we will not forget them
two weeks ago I set out our roadmap for
the next phase in our fight against
kovat 19 and it's a cautious plan
informed by the evidence about what is
safe and its conditional upon our
continual progress against the virus and
we are making progress thanks to this
country's collective efforts the key
indicators are heading in the right
direction the daily number of deaths is
done the number of new cases is done our
survey evidence suggests the infection
rate is falling and the R has not risen
above 1 so just over two weeks ago we
moved to step one of our plan
encouraging those who are unable to work
from home to go back to work
with new guidelines setting out how
workplaces can be made Coby
secur at the same time we allowed people
to spend more time outdoors and to meet
one member of another household outside
provided they remain two metres apart I
also said we will be able to move to
step two of our plan no earlier than
Monday the 1st of June a week today we
will set out our formal assessment of
the five tests that we set for adjusting
the lockdown later this week as part of
the three weekly review we are legally
required to undertake by Thursday but
because of the progress we are making I
can with confidence put the British
people on notice of the changes we
intend to introduce as we move
interceptive and I think it's important
to give that notice so that people have
sufficient time to adjust and get ready
before those changes come into effect
yesterday I set out our intention to
begin reopening nurseries and particular
years in primary schools reception year
1 year 6 from the 1st of June followed
by some contact for those secondary
school pupils with exams next year from
the 15th of June some contact 4-year
years 10 and 12 from the 15th of June
with their with their teachers this
announcement has given schools teachers
and parents clarity about our intentions
enabling them to prepare in earnest the
Department for Education is now engaging
with teaching unions councils and school
leaders to help schools get ready today
I want to give the retail sector notice
of our intentions to reopen shops so
they too can get ready so I can announce
that it is our intention to allow
outdoor markets to reopen from June the
1st subject to all premises being made
koban secured as well as car showrooms
which often had significant outdoor
space and where it is Jen generally
easier to apply social distancing
we know that the transmission of the
virus is lower outdoors and that it is
easier to follow covert secure
guidelines in open spaces that means we
can allow we can also allow outdoor
markets to reopen in a safe way that
does not risk causing a second wave of
the virus then from the 15th of June we
intend to allow all other non-essential
retail ranging from department stores to
small independent shops to reopen again
this change will be contingent upon
progress against the five tests and will
only be permitted for those retail
premises which are coded secure today we
are publishing new guidance for the
retail sector detailing the measures
they should take to meet the necessary
social distancing and hygiene standards
shops now have the time to implement
this guidance before they reopen and
this will ensure there can be no doubt
about what steps they should take while
the vast majority of businesses will
want to do everything possible to
protect their staff and customers I
should add that we will of course have
the powers we need to enforce compliance
where that is required I want people to
be confident that they can shop safely
provided they follow the social
distancing rules for all premises the
food retail sector has already responded
fantastically well enabling supermarkets
to be kept open in a safe way and we
will learn lessons from that experience
as we allow other retail to open these
are careful but deliberate steps on the
road to rebuilding our country and we
can only take these steps thanks to what
we have so far achieved together we will
only be successful you'll only be
successful if we all remember the basics
so wash your hands keep social distance
and isolate if you have symptoms and get
a